depuis hier neuf cent mille travailleurs
au pays bénéficie davantage
supplémentaires grâce à des
modifications au code canadien du
travail
chaque employé dans un secteur sous
réglementation fédérale comme les
banques et compagnies aériennes les
sociétés de transport notamment en
maintenant droit à une pause non
rémunéré d'au moins 30 minutes après
chaque période de cinq heures de travail
consécutives
il doit aussi y avoir une période de
repos d'une durée minimale de huit
heures consécutives entre chaque quart
de travail sauf en cas d'urgence
l'employeur doit viser par écrit 24
heures à l'avancé un employé dont le
quart de travail est modifié il ya
beaucoup d'autres choses également simon
gaudreault et directeur principal de la
recherche national à la fédération
canadienne de l'entreprise indépendante
bonsoir bonsoir
les syndicats ont salué ces
changements-là à la basse en disant
voilà des changements progressifs des
mesures qui aident les travailleurs vous
vous dites que ces changements-là
n'annonce rien de bon pour les pme
pourquoi ça touche 18 mais l'employeur
aussi ces changements-là au code du
travail fédéral dont un grand nombre a
évidemment
un au québec et dans différentes
industries comme les transports comme le
mais la manipulation des grains les
télécommunications aussi alors pour ces
entreprises là on est venu rajouter
d'autres obligations
donc on est venu un peu et rigidifier le
cadre du travail et donc on est venu
retirer en conséquence de la flexibilité
dans certaines industries la réalité de
l'industrie fait simplement que c'est
pas toujours évident de donner un
horaire de travail 96 heures en quatre
jours à l'avancé comme on le voudrait on
pense au domaine des transports là où il
y aura toutes fins pratiques plus
d'entrepôts dans notre économie on doit
expédier des marchandises très vite donc
c'est ce qui nous préoccupe
cela dit le gouvernement dit voilà une
façon d'améliorer la productivité de
faire en sorte que les travailleurs ont
de bons avantages travail dans un
contexte agréable
est ce que ça ne devrait pas préoccupé
également les employeurs je pense que
les employeurs ont pas le choix de se
préoccuper de productivité de
compétitivité à tout moment on est dans
un dans une économie qui est très
compétitive à l'heure actuelle cela
étant dit si on veut leur donner les
meilleurs outils pour demeurer
compétitive
il faut leur donner au contraire de plus
de rigidité de la flexibilité pour
qu'elle puisse être innovatrice incluant
dans la manière dont elles gèrent leur
main d'oeuvre dans un contexte de
pénurie de main d'oeuvre donc des
travailleurs plus heureux au mieux au
travail c'est de régis dit fier selon
vous
l'énorme travail d'encadrement du
travail faudrait voir si dans tous les
cas de figure ça va les rendre plus
heureux parce que lorsqu'on a des
industries par exemple on revient au
domaine du transport où on veut par
exemple donner des horaires de travail
quatre jours à l'avancé
pas vraiment possible est ce qu'on avait
dans le contexte actuel des employés qui
étaient heureuses de leur équilibre
parce qu'en contrepartie peut-être
d'horreur qui arrive un peu plus vite
on avait des plus longues périodes de
congés ou on avait des salaires plus
élevés et là on est venu contraindre les
entreprises est ce que ces exemples
est ce que c'est parce que le vent est
toujours viable parce que l'organisation
de ces entreprises doivent être toujours
viable on peut se poser la question se
dit il ya une très longue liste
d'exemption il ya beaucoup de ces
postes-là on dit qu'on veut faire des
changements pour 900 mille travailleurs
mais il ya toutes sortes d'exemption
qu'il faudra voir dans le détail qui
font en sorte que avec ces changements
l'on visait justement ces secteurs où ça
fonctionne 24 heures par jour 7 jours
par semaine qui font en sorte qu'ils
aient beaucoup d'exemption notamment
dans le transport
oui donc il ya à la fois incertaine
nouvelles règles qui s'appliquent par
tranches c'est-à-dire y en a qui sont
entrées en vigueur
supposément le 1er septembre de cette
année et d'autres qui vont entrer en
vigueur en 2020 et il ya d'étrange par
l'industrie ce que la ministre dit il ya
très récemment il ya quelques jours
c'est qu'il considérerait des exemptions
c'est pas très clair où on se situe
présentement alors ça aussi ça devrait
être clarifié un important lieu de
l'incertitude et comme vous savez c'est
pas bon lot d'un point de vue de gestion
des relations de travail je crois que à
la fois les employeurs et les les
travailleurs les employés vont vouloir
avoir plus de certitudes est courte et
vous avez dit supposément à partir du
1er septembre ce que je comprends qu'il
ya de vos membres qui ne vont pas
appliquer les nouvelles normes non les
les employeurs écouter vont se conformer
à la réglementation c'est juste qu'en
fonction des signaux que l'ont entendu
de la part de la ministre dans les
derniers jours il disait qu'elle devait
consulter son ministère pour reconnaître
qu'elle en extension s'appliquerait et
qu'elle allait à toute fin pratique et
nous revenir là dessus on n'a toujours
pas nécessairement ces informations là
et le 1er septembre c'était hier alors
va falloir avoir des précisions
rapidement vous demander une exemption
permanente pour les entreprises du
secteur des transports donc permanent
vraiment personne dans le secteur des
transports ne devrait toucher par les
changements
c'est à dire qu'il faut regarder les
différentes modalités dans ce qui a été
annoncé comme changements au code
canadien du travail il faut regarder ce
qui s'applique plus ou moins bien au
secteur des transports j'ai mentionné
l'horaire de travail quatre jours à
l'avant sous même s'ils ont modifié un
quart de travail on doit le faire 24
heures à l'avancé alors fraudeurs
regarder ce plus en détails pour que ça
colle davantage à la réalité de ces
industries aux entreprises de moins de
50 employés
c'est la majorité des entreprises
lorsqu'on regarde les entreprises de
moins de 50 employés on parle d'environ
90 95 % de nos entreprises faute
faudrait voir comment cette distribution
le s'applique dans le par exemple dans
le secteur des transports
mais il ya une chose qui est sûre c'est
que on envoie de ces exemptions
l'appareil d'employés d'ailleurs les
changements qui sont annoncés parmi ceux
qui arrivent en 2020 sur l'équité un
plat d'équité salariale
il ya un seuil ça s'applique aux
entreprises de 10 employés et plus alors
c'est courant de voir serait ce qu une
mesure qui vous plaît dans le change
dans les changements bah écoute et
encore une fois comme comme je voulais
dit c'est sûr qu'avec le statu quo qu'on
avait auparavant
les employeurs et les employés de notre
point de vue arriver à trouver une
situation d'équilibré et il y avait de
la marge de manoeuvre pour que selon les
industries et selon les entreprises on
trouve un modèle bien spécifique qui
faisait gagnant gagnant d'un point de
vue devenir rigidifier davantage c'est
un hydro pas à s'adapter
simon gaudreault merci beaucoup merci
aussi bien